covid19 has encouraged many of us to
look at how we might optimize our immune
responses
through supplements or superfoods but is
it even possible to alter how the body
responds to disease through an immune
boosting pill or by eating blueberries
and what about the people who take it
even further the biohackers
experimenting with procedures such as
fecal transplants basically taking
someone else's poo
as a medicine in an attempt to cure
range of ills
dangerous experimentation or smart
science
[Music]
the immune system is part of an
interconnected system running
all the way through our body involving
all our tissues
from our skin all the way through to our
toes
and in fact the gut has one of the
largest resident populations of immune
cells
in our body most of the body's immune
cells are found in the lining of the
intestine
and the microbes in our gut play a
crucial role in keeping those immune
cells of our body
healthy they do that by providing with
key chemical signals
that they get once they digest the good
foods that we eat
so a healthy gut microbiome is
absolutely crucial to a healthy immune
system the immune system is considered
to be an organ
but unlike every other organ in your
body it's one where components of the
system
can migrate around the body you don't
expect that with
cells from your lungs or your spleen or
any other solid organ
but the beauty of the immune system is
it has a property of immunosurveillance
immunological surveillance is when the
cells of the immune system come together
to coordinate a response to an external
threat
such as disease for example your lymph
nodes
the glands that swell up when you are
sick are a sign of your immune system at
work
we often hear messages encouraging us to
boost our immune system
so could we just take a pill to do that
when you do meet an infectious threat
our immune response has to react quickly
to contain the threat and eradicate it
and you don't want it to stay on because
if it stays on
it's damaging and that is what happens
in allergy and autoimmune disease which
are over-reactivity
of the immune response so there is no
wonder pill that's going to restore and
boost
one part of the immune response to help
us
be super-powered because it's also
interconnected
and the risks of getting it wrong are
really
quite dramatic so instead of boosting
our immune system we should focus on
supporting it everything that we know
already which is good for our health
will also benefit our immune system more
exercise
taking at regular intervals has been
shown to boost your immune function
that's been shown and that's published
data unfortunately the
lifestyle is not very good for our
immune system
our diets of convenience foods and
fatty foods that are low in fiber
alongside sedentary lifestyles with
little exercise
high stress and not too much sleep too
much screening time
all of these combine to make our immune
response
not work as it should getting enough
sleep and reducing stress can help our
immune system operate at an optimal
level and even though one blueberry
won't work miracles
getting a variety of the right foods is
very important
to help your immunity you need to be
feeding up your gut microbes and the
best way to do this to make them more
diverse
give them more species and i recommend
30 different types of plant a week which
gives you
all the fiber you should need secondly
you should pick plants to eat that are
high in polyphenols
these are the chemicals that are
naturally found in plants and
are actually rocket fuel for your gut
microbes so things like brightly colored
berries strong flavors like coffee beans
dark chocolate and even red wine contain
polyphenols
so if what you eat and your gut is so
important for your immune system
why are some people transplanting other
people's poo into their own stomachs
[Music]
fecal microbial transplant or
colloquially a poo transplant
is taking a sample of
a stool from a normal person and putting
it into someone
who's unwell this has been done for
several decades for
very bad infections of the bowel like
clostridium difficile and it cures 90
percent of people
and it's been since started to be used
in a number of other conditions
this is a fascinating area of research
but
definitely not to be tried at home says
tim i think this is an exciting new form
of therapy
but it's always best to do this within
the confines of a medical clinic
where things can be supervised and the
risk
of side effects or infection is
extremely low there are some people who
take risks and do do it at home and
those risks will be multiplied
considerably there's a lot of hype about
fecal transplants and you mustn't
believe people who say that it works in
everything
in everybody it certainly doesn't and
there are many failures in clinical
trials
one of the ways we can effectively and
safely manipulate our immune responses
is through vaccination
what a vaccine is doing is essentially
giving you the parts
of the germ that will stimulate the
immune response
without actually getting the full-blown
infection another thing that we can do
is actually try to switch the immune
response off
for some diseases we don't want a
powerful immune response because that's
what's causing the damage
this is exactly what's done in diseases
like
rheumatoid arthritis multiple sclerosis
or is also being investigated infections
like covert
the good news is whilst there's no one
magic pill we can take to boost our
immune response
the more scientists learn about how our
immune system works the more they can
develop
new drug treatments and therapies to
combat a wide range of diseases
the knowledge of science is actually
leading to all sorts of wonderful new
possibilities to help treat us
and win the war against infection thanks
for watching
if you enjoyed that be sure to check out
these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification
each time we upload a new video